look uh
you know you've uh it's kind of
emotional
for me look you're with me my whole
career
and uh through the good times and the
bad i want to thank you for everything
to my fellow delawareans on behalf of
the entire biden family
that's here today i want to express how
much you mean
to me and to every one of us you know in
our family
the values we share the character we
strive
for the way we view the world it all
comes from home it all comes from
delaware
the state that gave my mother and father
a home and a livelihood
when they needed it most the state that
made my brother and sister and i both of
whom were here
understand that we could do whatever we
dreamed of
whatever that was and it gave me a
chance
when i was just a kid to be elected me
to uh
and believed in me and sent me to the
united states senate before going to the
county council
after going to county council where jill
and i
found one another and where she made me
strong as
ernest hemingway wrote in all the broken
places
and the state that loves our children
and our grandchildren
and loved our beau and he so loved you
right back
general barry when the headquarters was
named after beau
i told general vavil at the time it
means everything to me
to hunter to ashley to jill to our whole
family
but beau would be the first to say the
honor goes to the men and women
of the delaware national guard and their
families
who gave so much were true patriots
defined by the courage of their
character
and so it's deeply personal that our
next journey to washington starts here
a place that defines the very best
of who we are as americans i know the
i know these are dark times but there's
always light
that's what makes this state so special
that's what it taught me
it taught me the most there's always
light when i came home after graduating
from delaware and then going on to law
school
at syracuse i came home after law school
to wilmington to our county
it had gone dark dr king
was assassinated wilmington had been in
flames the national guard
patrol the streets and that turmoil
inspired me to become a public defender
a step i never anticipated would lead me
toward this improbable journey
12 years ago i was waiting at the train
station in wilmington
for a black man to pick me up on our way
to washington
where we were sworn in as president
and vice president of the united states
of america
and here we are today my family and i
about to return to washington
to meet a black woman a south asian
descent
to be sworn in as president and vice
president
of the united states
as i told beau on that station waiting
for barack and hunter i said
ashley i said don't tell me things can't
change
they can and they do that's america
that's delaware a place of hope and
light
and limitless possibilities and i'm
honored
i'm truly honored to be your next
president and commander-in-chief
and i'll always be a proud son of the
state of delaware
as tommy or better known as the chairman
carper
senator carper knows my colleagues in
the senate used to always kid me for
quoting irish poets
they thought i did it because i'm irish
i didn't do it for that reason
i did it because they're the best poets
in the world
and james joyce james joyce was said to
have told a friend
that when he's come when it comes his
time to pass
when he dies he said dublin
dublin we've written on my heart
well excuse the emotion
but
when i die delaware written on my heart
in the hearts
[Applause]
hearts of all but all of us all the
bidens
we love you all we you've been there for
us
in the good and the bad you've never
walked away
and uh i am proud proud proud proud
to be a son of delaware and i am
even more proud to be standing here
doing this from the major beau biden
facility ladies and gentlemen
i only have one regret he's not here
because he should be introducing him as
president
but we have great opportunities
delaware's taught us anything's possible
anything's possible in this country so
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops
thank you